dans l'actualité ce soir la birmanie
durement frappé le bilan du cyclone
nargis s'est alourdi à dix mille morts
au moins la dictature militaire au
pouvoir acceptent de s'ouvrir à l'aide
internationale
encore un seuil symbolique pour le prix
du pétrole le baril a dépassé pour la
première fois les 120 dollars les
experts ne voient aucune accalmie se
dessinait en france qui en veut à
olivier besancenot on l'a appris en fin
d'après midi le porte parole de la lcr a
été espionné pendant plusieurs mois par
une officine privée de renseignement
olivier besancenot est notre invité
bonsoir et à tout à l'heure
nicolas sarkozy fêtera discrètement
demain le premier anniversaire de son
élection ce soir au delà du style
enquête sur le bilan c'est le dossier de
cette édition
le lancement officiel du passeport
biométrique qui remplacera peu à peu le
passeport électronique il intégrera une
puce contenant une photo et des
empreintes digitales numérisées
enfin la disparition d'une voix
familière lucien jeunesse qui avait
incarné pendant trente ans le fameux jeu
des mille francs est mort à 89
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous il aura donc
fallu trois jours pour mesurer l'ampleur
des ravages provoqués par le cyclone
nargis sambi rhmani ce soir les
autorités parlent de 10000 morts il y
aurait plusieurs centaines de milliers
de sans abri les dernières images
commentées par richard binet
voici les rares images qui nous
parviennent de birmanie sur des
kilomètres des terres et des villages
engloutis par les eaux qui donne la
mesure du désastre des 10000 morts
annoncés par les autorités birmanes
risque de n'être qu'un bilan provisoire
poussé par des vents dépassant les 140
kilomètres heure les eaux du golfe du
bengale se sont engouffrés dans les rues
de rangoun l'ancienne capitale
mêlant baissé d'intensité mais les
habitants des bidonvilles de cette
mégapole de cinq millions d'habitants
continue à fuy nous est insalubre et les
bouteilles d'eau minérale se vend à prix
d'or mais c'est dans le sud du pays que
la situation est la plus préoccupante
le cyclone est arrivés par l'ouest et
plusieurs villages côtiers auraient été
rayées de la carte
la croix-rouge déjà présentes sur le
terrain tentent de parer au plus pressé
en attendant l'aide internationale
massive qui permettra de soulager les
centaines de milliers de sans abri qui
attendent dans les campagnes birman
bonsoir cyril payen vous êtes le
correspondant de france 24 en thaïlande
pays voisins de la birmanie et grâce à
des témoignages vous avez pu obtenir
d'autres informations
effectivement ces témoignages viennent
de la zone du delta ce sont les premiers
rescapés de cette zone du delta qui a
été largement frappée par le cyclone
samedi et ce sont des témoignages
terribles des selon ccc rescapés des
centaines de corps jonchent les routes
et les rives il semble qu'il y ait eu en
même temps que le cyclone une vaste
dépression tropicale qui a provoqué une
subite montée des eaux dont la plupart
de ces centaines des milliers de
cadavres sont des noyers et sur le
terrain c'est la troisième nuit pour des
centaines de milliers de birmans coupés
du monde sans électricité sans eau
courante sans vivre et pour donner un
état de la pénurie sur place ont dit cet
après midi à rangoun
des résidents ont commencé à boire l'eau
du lac inya qu'est le grand lac du
centre de rangoon depuis rangoun
donc on est vraiment dans une énorme
catastrophe naturelle en birmanie ce
soir merci cyril payen il faut savoir
que la birmanie est l'un des pays les
plus pauvres et les plus fermés du monde
cette catastrophe intervient après la
révolte des moines bouddhistes
il ya sept mois claude samper ce pays un
peu plus grand que la france compte 50
millions d'habitants
depuis 46 ans il est dirigé par l'armée
quatre cent mille soldats avec à leur
tête le généralissime than shwe
à 75 ans l'homme fait ce qu'il veut
quand il veut
en 2006 par exemple il décide de
déplacer la capitale rangoon dans une
nouvelle ville n'est pido construite de
toutes pièces en pleine jungle
face aux militaires les rares tentatives
de protestation sont très sévèrement
réprimée en septembre dernier les
manifestations des moines se termine
dans un bain de sang depuis 40 ans une
femme elle toute seule symbolise la
résistance face à la dictature
aung san suu kyi prix nobel de la paix
elle commence son combat c'est premier
rassemblement alors qu'elle a une
vingtaine d'années
la voici en septembre dernier à la porte
de sa résidence qu'elle ne peut quitter
elle a aujourd'hui 62 ans la birmanie le
170e pays le plus pauvre au monde
pourtant le pays possède d'importantes
richesses du gaz du tech du cuivre du
pétrole mais cela ne profite qu'à la
junte militaire en france d'abord
l'actualité économique c'est demain que
les discussions vont commencer entre le
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
sur la réforme du chômage
en clair quels seront les nouvelles
conditions fixées aux demandeurs
d'emploi pour toucher des indemnités
le site internet du journal les échos a
révélé ce matin la dernière version du
projet explication syriza dans le projet
gouvernemental
l'offre raisonnable d'emploi est à
prendre en compte au bout de trois mois
de chômage
à qualifications égales le demandeur
d'emploi devraient alors accepté une
offre dont le salaire représenterait 95%
de son ancienne rémunération au delà de
six mois
le chômeur devrait accepter un emploi
rémunéré cette fois ci à 80% du salaire
antérieur nouvelles conditions il doit
pouvoir se déplacer dans une zone
n'excédant pas une heure de transport en
commun
au bout d'un an le demandeur d'emploi
sera obligé d'accepter un poste rémunéré
un salaire supérieur à l'allocation
chômage qu'il perçoit un peu plus de 57
% de ce qu'il touchait précédemment
enfin le projet prévoit de nouvelles
sanctions
deux offres refusées entraînerait une
radiation de deux mois et donc une
suspension provisoire de l'allocation
chômage des dispositions dont la
ministre de l'économie débattra demain
avec les partenaires sociaux
et parallèlement à cette démarche qui
concernera tous les chômeurs une
disposition particulière du plan
banlieue de fadela amara est en train de
voir le jour l'état va demander à l'anpe
wade organismes privés de prendre en
main les moins de 26 ans dans les
quartiers sensibles pour les former aux
entretiens d'embauché
en anglais on appelle ça du coaching
l'expérience existe déjà en portage
jérôme hermet bruno girodon il y a peut
encore mettre une cravate était pour lui
impensable c'était pas mon truc quoi
j'étais pas dans dance des vers en fait
comment
bon il ya encore un peu de travail mais
il ya six mois benjamin salle moon était
sans diplôme sans emploi jusqu'à ce que
la haine pe lui propose une formation
d'un type nouveau
un coaching trois semaines intensives
financé par l'état
au menu des jeux de rôle et un travail
sur l'attitude jusqu'à réapprendre à
marcher de trouver les choses ne -
beaulieu et en quelques semaines
benjamin a trouvé un emploi agent de
sécurité un cdi et un nouvel état
d'esprit je m'habille et pas comme il
faut on va dire peut-être jean ii par
exemple les t-shirts et les gros logo
les machins les pulls banlieue machin
j'arrivais comme ça j'avais ma casquette
même si je lui enlever ça fait pas un
très bon aperçu la façon de parler aussi
parce qu'on a ça m'a appris aussi à bien
articuler avoir un accent un peu plus
correct en raison à deux pas de ces
quartiers où le chômage des jeunes
tournent autour des 40 %
voici la société de coaching cité en
modèle
ici les mots de la réussite sont sur les
murs toujours à porter des regards
les recettes de ce coach un travail en
équipe et un suivi minutieux des
stagiaires fois je me dis si une grosse
commande
je préfère lui demande moi même j'y vais
l'une monde
excusez-moi faisiez coup d'oeil en six
mois d'existence 8 coacher sur dix ont
trouvé un emploi dans les semaines qui
suivent ce type de prestation c'est ce
que les cadres achète ce que les
entreprises achètent donc pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne ferait pas la même qualité à
des à des jeunes issus des quartiers
populaires avec ses méthodes pour cadre
evans a en quelques semaines effacées
trois ans d'échecs et de frustration ça
m'a donné plus d'assurance
ça m'a permis de voir des compétences en
moi que je connaissais pas au départ
coaché pendant 60 jours
il y en a fallu beaucoup moins pour
décrocher un cdi d'assistante
commerciale dans une entreprise de la
ville voisine
son coaching aura coûté 1500 euros aux
collectivités et la secrétaire d'état à
la ville fadela amara a fait savoir que
45 mille jeunes seront concernés que ce
contrat sera doté de 250 millions
d'euros sur trois ans à propos d'emploi
sachez que des haines c'est l'un des
derniers grands groupes textiles
français est placée en redressement
judiciaire décision du tribunal de
commerce de paris
1100 salariés sont concernés
principalement en alsace l'envolée sans
fin du pétrole le baril a franchi la
barre des 120 dollars aujourd'hui sur le
marché de new york nouvel eos attribués
à des perturbations sur des sites de
production au nigeria
on l'a déjà évoqué c'est un doublement
des cours en un an rien n'indique que la
tendance pourrait s'inverser les
répercussions se font sentir dans les
stations essence et les pompistes voit
apparaître par exemple de nouveaux
comportements des automobilistes
reportage et ni briffa stéphane
guillemot à plus d'un euro 50 le litre
de sans plomb
il préfère arrêter les frais rapidement
leurs solutions
des mini plein il ne compte plus en
litres mais en euros pourquoi 30 euros
cette nouvelle est un peu cher et en
haïti a plus la cote et chez moi qui
fais
presque 10 centimes de différence
basilique ont fait de cana touron mecs
d'en mettre plus
non même nom - le français qui colle au
gicm ans des mini plein ce n'est pas
forcément le meilleur calcul s'en
prennent pas vous donner ma version
on savait aux mêmes qui font des petits
despatie et avaient souvent donc enfin
comme le colloque ont beau jour en jour
pour qu'ils payent plus cher les
conducteurs de plus en plus rusés car en
deux ans les prix n'ont cessé de grimper
le gasoil qui est le carburant le plus
utilisé le plus consommé en france avait
un prix moyen en 2006 2 1 061 10 euros à
la bombe
aujourd'hui il a passé la barre des 1,30
résultat dans cette station les ventes
de carburant ont chuté de 30% en un an
par jour au [ __ ] à peu près 17 militants
tous produits confondus
quand je dis on est à 12 me en 2011
milan au niveau national en un an les
ventes d'essence ont diminué de 6%
on en vient maintenant à cette étrange
affaire d'espionnage visant olivier
besancenot l'express.fr révèle qu'une
officine privée de renseignement l'a
suivi light pied pendant plusieurs mois
avec des complicités puisque ses comptes
en banque par exemple ont été visités le
porte parole de la lcr est avec nous
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
d'abord les faits franck genauzeau ça
miaule email l'histoire est digne d'un
roman policier au moins quatre mois de
surveillance étroite révèle lexpress.fr
d'octobre 2007 à janvier dernier le
leader de la lcr et photographié en bas
de chez lui ses proches et pied son
emploi du temps
décortiquer les détectives privés
cherche même à vérifier s'il possède un
puissant 4 4 il découvre en fait qu'il
roule en peugeot 106 avec une galerie
sur le toit précise le rapport qui
n'omet aucun détail moins anecdotique
certaines informations confidentielles
sont récupérer son numéro de compte
bancaire par exemple
voilà que des gens le suivent suivent sa
compagne suivre son enfant il
photographie éventuellement vérifier
dans quelle école maternelle apparemment
et qu' il se rend l'enfant
il ya ce sont des méthodes qui n'ont pas
cours de démocratie donc c'est
inquiétant olivier besancenot et son
parti ont décidé de porter plainte puis
a commandité cet espionnage et pourquoi
c'est ce que l'enquêté devra déterminer
olivier besancenot vous avez appris
cette information il ya quelques heures
seulement je crois votre réaction vous
êtes choqués voilà la réaction c'est
c'est la surprise
oui puis puis la révolte en effet j'ai
appris comme vous en effet que c'est
kitsch de plus agréable dans la vie de
savoir qu'on a été pendant probablement
du mois d'octobre au mois de janvier
mis sous surveillance suivie filet ce
qui était le cas aussi pour ma compagne
mon enfant de 4 ans et demi maintenant
moi je suis pas dans le genre
paranoïaque je suis pas dans le genre
non plus pleurnichard je suis pas le
premier militant anticapitaliste et
révolutionnaire avoir été filé je
constate simplement que ma vie privée a
été atteinte donc on porte plainte
contre x pour que notamment pour
atteinte à la vie privée pour qu'une
enquête soit faite et savoir quelles
sont finalement les ce qu'on
commanditait tout ça voilà vous
soupçonniez quelque chose
écoutez tout ça moi je souhaite le dire
à ceux et celles qui mèneront une
enquête si on a eu dans tous les cas je
le souhaite je souhaite savoir si cette
filature et 6,7 me surveillance et lieu
si oui qu il l'a fait
et puis dans ce cadre-là pouvoir pouvoir
m'expliquer un minimum je pense que ce
serait la moindre des choses
vous imaginiez de telles méthodes à
écouter des méthodes comme ça elle
continue malheureusement dans la société
dans laquelle on est on sait que le
combat des petits contre les gros et pas
toujours à pied d'égalité
maintenant moi je fais partie de ce
mouvement qui combat les intérêts d'une
minorité qui exploite la majorité de la
population qui dénonce la politique du
gouvernement
je sais qu'il ya un prix à payer à tout
ça mais je cherche aussi à protéger ma
vie privée
ma famille en l'occurrence de de tous
ces dégâts là qui sont absolument
inadmissible et révoltant alors qu'ils
peuvent autant vouloir selon vous est ce
que vous pensez à une piste politique
écoutez moi je n'en sais strictement
rien voilà je suis absolument comme vous
j'ai appris les faire par le biais de
cette enquête qui a été menée par un
journaliste de l'express c'est pour ça
qu'on porte plainte pour
avoir la vérité que la lumière soit
faite et qu'on puisse continuer cet
engagement militant voilà qu'on continue
à faire depuis des mois et des mois
c'est peut-être celui-là qui gênent
finalement parce que le site du magazine
évoque une autre piste celui d'un
fabriquer de ces pistolets à décharge
électrique le tazer que vous aviez mis
en cause pendant la campagne
présidentielle en disant il a provoqué
150 morts aux etats unis tazer a porté
plainte et il y aura bientôt une
audience mais écoutez ça c'est à la
justice de le dire en effet vous l'avez
rappelé pendant la campagne
présidentielle avec d'autres d'ailleurs
j'ai fait état d'un rapport qui est
celui d'amnesty international qui
explique que l'utilisation de ce
pistolet à décharge électrique aux états
unis au canada a provoqué de façon
directe ou indirecte
plus de 200 personnes ce qui est quand
même pas rien et moi j'ai fait que
réclamer dans le cadre de cette campagne
un moratoire
c'est à dire qu'on prenne du temps pour
savoir si oui ou non en armant par
exemple la police municipale ce qui
risque de se faire dans quelques
semaines on rajoute un problème au
problème voilà donc c'était dire un
aimant mais j'ai aucune connaissance je
peux absolument pas vous dire si c'est
lié au panier on a compris que vous
attendez l' enquête de la police et de
la justice pour savoir d'où viennent ces
filatures questions politiques tout de
même vous voyez l'actualité les à nantes
nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée votre
sentiment votre commentaire on imagine
que vous applaudissez pas des deux mains
mais est ce que vous reprochez
finalement nicolas sarkozy d'avoir
appliqué son programme de l'avoir pas
assez appliqué
je dirais qu'il ya une cohérence celle
du libéralisme dans la situation
politique économique et plus la même que
celle liée à un an
aujourd'hui non seulement il ya une
contestation sociale extrêmement forte
on va le constater encore le 15 mai avec
une journée importante pour l'éducation
nationale et le 22 mai contre le projet
de réforme du gouvernement sur les
retraites
mais il ya en plus nouveauté une crise
financière qui plombent l'activité
économique et qui fait qu'on sait
parfaitement que le gouvernement nicolas
sarkozy n'a plus les moyens de sa propre
politique
ce qui fait que le gouvernement actuel
peut se retrouver en effet pris en
tenaille entre d'un côté une
illégitimité de plus en plus forte
contesté par la rue et l'autre côté une
urgence économique il rattrape ça ça
peut être la clé pour des mobilisations
sociales victorieuse donc ce combat
militant ça devrait être le combat tous
les militants de gauche
j'avais de façon particulièrement
enthousiaste et et par rapport à ce qu
ont discuté avant je voudrais dire à ce
qu aurait pu commander ce type d'
enquête par exemple d'un autre âge que
les coups de pression ça marchera pas on
continuera ce combat de façon
extrêmement motivé merci
accepté notre invitation merci alors on
en vient précisément à ce premier
anniversaire de l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy ce sera en fête demain le 6 mai
le président de la république va
recevoir à cette occasion les membres du
gouvernement et leurs conjoints à
l'elysée mais la fête dit on sera assez
discrète
il faut dire que le climat est plutôt
morose les sondages peu flatteur alors
dans un instant on va faire le bilan des
réformes mais d'abord l'état d'esprit
des militants et des sympathisants ump
dans une ville moyenne ou nicolas
sarkozy l'avait emporté l'an dernier à
evreux reportage alban nicosie mathias
marois soit il a trop de conseillers
auquel cas c'est vrai que ça peut brûler
gérer l'écart eu le choix il les écoute
pas mais sont parfois sévères pourtant à
la table du café des élus et des cadres
ump dans ce fief jeudi chiraquien
l'électorat de droite accepte
difficilement la méthode sarkozy
ce changement il je pense que les
français n'y était pas préparé on a
collé le mot réforme tous les sujets ça
passe pas quoi et ça a beaucoup gêné les
gens notamment une catégorie d'âge
personnes relativement âgées
il faut dire pourquoi au conte fait
comme on le fait quand on fait evreux
60000 habitants il y a un an la ville a
donné une majorité à nicolas sarkozy
dans la foulée deux députés ump sont
élus bruno le maire connaît bien sa
circonscription
voici ce qu'il entend pas on sait qu'à
des choses
mais il faut y aller en deçà en 12
heures il va filer augmenter son salaire
ouvrier d'un poupon blanc il ne peut pas
sentir le malheur des autres
le pouvoir d'achat thème central des
critiques surtout dans ce quartier
populaire
la madeleine quinze mille habitants
chômage précarité quelquefois insécurité
l'an dernier le candidat sarkozy a fait
pourtant de très bons scores l'électorat
populaire est plus indulgent
c'était peut-être le côté blé blé mais
maintenant ça commence à s'améliorer
alors là aussi bruno le maire argumente
mais surtout entend des critiques qu'ils
s'engagent à faire suivre à l'elysée on
est là pour aider le présent république
et le gouvernement a avancé un député
qui n'aurait plus sa liberté de parole
c'est un réputé inutile pour la majorité
aux dernières municipales evreux a
basculé à gauche c'est l'opposition qui
célèbre désormais les mariages quant à
l'union de nicolas sarkozy avec la
france il est un peu tôt pour se
prononcer pour expliquer la déception
qu'on entend souvent on a beaucoup parlé
du style sarkozy de la manière d'exercer
la fonction
ce soir nous évoquons le bilan des
réformes qu'elles étaient les promesses
quelles sont les réalisations
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé alexandre kara je ne voudrais pas
6 mai 2007 6 mai 2008
douze mois après que sont devenues les
promesses du candidat sarkozy l'ump
dénombre 55 réformes déjà réalisées
voici les principales je veux être le
président de l'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir d'achat les français
ont le sentiment pour l'instant que les
mesures sont inefficaces
pourtant engagements tenus avec la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et le paiement des
retraités mais sur ce sujet nicolas
sarkozy est rattrapé par le principe de
réalité
s'agissant d'ailleurs du pouvoir d'achat
qu'est ce que vous attendez de moins que
je vide des caisses qui sont déjà vides
parmi les promesses réalisé il y encore
le bouclier fiscal à hauteur de 50% des
revenus ou l'allègement des droits de
succession
en revanche le déficit public se creuse
toujours même si officiellement
l'objectif reste le retour à l'équilibré
en 2012
du coup la baisse des impôts promise
pendant la campagne est ajournée je
ferai également la réforme des régimes
spéciaux de retraite les régimes
spéciaux comme le service minimum deux
réformes menées à bien sans conflit
social majeur et cela grâce à un
dialogue social renouvelé sans doute
l'un des succès de cette première année
du quinquennat
au même moment le revenu de solidarité
active comme le plan banlieues sont
ajournés faute de financement nous ne
pouvons plus continuer à détruire notre
planète pour le candidat sarkozy
l'environnement figurer au rang des
priorités en terme d'affichage pari tenu
le grenelle est une réussite
les mesures concrètes elles se font
attendre et provoque même des blocages
dans la majorité comme sur le dossier
ogm
un fonctionnaire sur deux à la retraite
non remplacés c'était la promesse
un an plus tard la réforme avance le
chiffre est déjà demain sur trois je
veux des peines doublées pour les
multirécidivistes
là encore c'était l'un des engagements
forts de la campagne les peines plancher
pour les récidivistes sont votées la
carte judiciaire et remodelée mais au
prix de manifestations de magistrats
d'avocats et des nues
au chapitre éducation la loi sur
l'autonomie des universités a été voté
la suppression de la carte scolaire
actes et entrera en vigueur entre 2008
et 2010 ce soir la france et d'europe
pour l'europe un autre succès de nicolas
sarkozy le traité simplifié est en bonne
voie d'adoption par les 27 autres
promesses l'union pour la méditerranée
dont la création sera entériné en
juillet je veux être le président de la
france des droits de l'homme sur cette
question nicolas sarkozy a nettement
infléchi sa position
désormais les droits de l'homme ne sont
plus qu'un élément parmi d'autres de la
diplomatie française le parti socialiste
a célébré à sa façon cette première
année au pouvoir en lançant une campagne
de tracts et d'affichage intitulé un an
de désillusions et de régression
campagne insiste notamment sur les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat pour le ps
les français sont contraints de renoncer
à des dépenses quotidiennes image signée
franck brisset et puis un témoignage
plus personnel cette fois celui de la
mère du président de la république
andrée sarkozy qu'on a vu plusieurs fois
aux côtés son fils ces douze derniers
mois elle s'est confiée à richard boutry
de omega tv une télévision sur internet
michaël darmon andrée sarkozy c'est un
peu la première maman de france
aujourd'hui dans un entretien elle
revient sur les premiers pas de son fils
à l'elysée je me souviens que jour de la
passation des pouvoirs a été marquant
car c'était une fête de famille y avait
le terrible protocole de l'elysée et il
a été mis fin ce jour là est très
naturel très à l'aise pas du tout cela
d'elle on a vu que le cil changer
beaucoup
il avait relevé le caractère très
solennelle peut-être trop les gens
étaient un peu choqués au départ donc
s'il ya une personne qui n'a pas été
surprise par le tempérament
présidentielle c'est bien elle d'où
l'indulgence à propos de l'incident
salon de l'agriculture
ce gaspillage 13 franc et très naturelle
comme ça sur la table y voyant la
république emploi un gros mot mais ça ne
me paraît pas dramatique
cette ancienne avocate l'a pas sa langue
dans sa poche désormais sa seule
plaidoirie c'est pour défendre le bilan
du président malmené dans les sondages
c'est la reine des fées le président
sont tous il suivra très est là quand on
lui dit quand on lui demande contenue
parle de ces réformes par attendait il a
encore quatre ans chose qui n'a pas mal
emmanchée tout ça tout de même après le
divorce présidentielle andré sarkozy ne
souhaitait pas avoir son fils se
remarier mais le bilan de la nouvelle
épouse est jugé très positif
starlight initie qui réunit un nombre de
qualités tout de même assez exceptionnel
et très belle très intelligente très
drôle et très gentil c'est déjà à dinan
pour une bonne forme
nicolas sarkozy a emmené sa maman en
voyage
une seule fois c'était en chine à cette
époque il était encore célibataire j'ai
dis d'ailleurs à carling j'ai été
première balle pendant quinze jours
seulement à cause de vous et vous
pourrez voir l'intégralité de cet
entretien / oméga télé demain à partir
de 15h à l'étranger de nouvelles émeutes
liées à la pénurie alimentaire cette
fois en somalie à mogadiscio les
commerçants n'acceptent plus certains
moyens de paiement l'armée
gouvernementale a tiré sur la foule
au sénégal le président abdoulaye wade a
décidé d'accélérer sa révolution
agricole pour arriver à l'autosuffisance
il se donne six ans pour y parvenir en
particulier en favorisant la culture du
riz reportage dominique derda frédéric
guillot au sénégal comme ailleurs le
malheur des uns fait souvent le bonheur
des autres
avec la hausse spectaculaire du prix du
riz sur le marché mondial ces
cultivateurs du bord du fleuve n'ont
jamais aussi bien gagner leur intente
par chance on a pu acheter de l'engrais
un plus subventionnés alors on va
pouvoir faire deux récoltes une pendant
la saison sèche une autre après la
saison des pluies
cette coopérative qui regroupe près d'un
millier de riziculteurs est l'exemple le
meilleur sans doute de ce que le sénégal
voudrait faire pour parvenir à
l'autosuffisance alimentaire d'ici 2015
un pari ambitieux mais le pays ne manque
ni de terre ni d'eau ni de soleil des
atouts non négligeables pour relever un
tel défi
abdoulaye wade ne s'y est pas trompé lui
qui n'est jamais à court d'idées vient
de lancer sa grande offensive agricole
pour la nourriture et l'abondance
rien de moins il exhorte ses jeunes
sympathisants à se retrousser les
manches et à réinvestir les campagnes et
des équipements pour remporter cette
bataille le président sénégalais a
décidé d'employer les grands moyens
quinze mille hectares sont actuellement
comme ici aplani nivelé et entouré de
digues avant d'être attribué par une
commission spéciale à des agriculteurs
du nord du sénégal
ce qu'il faut c'est d'augmenter les
superficies aménagées poulies
si les moyens financiers existent il n'y
a pas de raison donc qu'on puisse pas
atteints d'autres suffisant dans les
damnés délai très raisonnable une vision
bien optimiste car à raison de 6 tonnes
de riz à l'hectare cultivait même avec
deux récoltes par an il faudrait
multiplier par trois la production
totale pour arriver aux 800 mille tonnes
que consomme chaque année la population
sénégalaise on en est encore bien loin
mais la volonté politique désormais là
et ça c'est nouveau et ce soir mots
croisés revient sur les émeutes de la
faim comment nourrir la planète c'est
l'intitulé du débat à suivre tour 10
lequel vit à partir de 23h15 en france
le lancement officiel du passeport
biométrique il remplacera peu à peu le
passeport électronique le décret a été
publié hier les premiers documents
seront distribués à l'automne ils
intègreront donc une puce contenant une
photo et des empreintes digitales
numérisées sinding boudaoud christophe
signale une photo numérisée et des
données personnelles comme vos nom
prénom adresse ou encore la couleur de
vos yeux stockés dans une puce
électronique
le nouveau passeport ressemblera à
l'actuel
à une chose près les empreintes
digitales de huit de vos dix doigts
seront également enregistré pour ses
passagers français qui s'envole pour les
états unis
ce nouveau document encore plus
sécurisée s'envole être source de
progrès je pense que ces passeports
versatilité les voyages nous nions d'en
faire un métier encore dans ces modèles
sera répertorié et on n'aura pas à
passer une douane chaque fois qu'on me
donnera le passeport soit toujours un
peu désagréable d'avoir ce genre de les
27 pays de l'union européenne s'était
engagé auprès des etats-unis a créé ce
nouveau passeport sécurisé en octobre
cinq départements tests seront équipés
de machines qui enregistreront
gratuitement vos photos et vos
empreintes
commencera alors la fabrication de ces
nouveaux passeports
le système sera généralisé à l'ensemble
du territoire en juin 2009
prix du nouveau document 60 euros comme
aujourd'hui vos passeports actuels
restent valables jusqu'à la fin de leur
période de validité
une opération coup-de-poing des pêcheurs
de cabillaud à boulogne-sur-mer ils ont
déversé le chargement d'un camion
néerlandais qui transportait selon eux
du cabillaud de trop petite taille
soulama illégale la gendarmerie maritime
elle a estimé qu'il était en grande
majorité réglementaire
les vacances sont passées pour deux
zones sur trois et les manifestations
reprennent des défilés sont attendus
dans plusieurs grandes villes demain des
défilés de lycéens
xavier darcos lui maintient ses projets
à l'appui de sa volonté de réforme il
invoque la baisse du niveau des élèves
français relativement à celui des pays
voisins
alors qu'en est il réellement éléments
de réponse avec mallorie ahounou et jean
yves bur est-ce qu'il est réactionnaire
de dire que dans les comparaisons
internationales nos élèves ne
réussissent pas bien un niveau scolaire
en baisse l'argument clé d'un ministre
qui défend ses réformes
que sait-on vraiment des performances
des élèves français est revenu
selon une étude récente les élèves
maîtrisent moins la lecture l'écriture
et le calcul qu'il y a vingt ans
l'orthographe notamment s'est dégradée
une dictée test a montré en 2005 qu'une
classe de 5e tombe au niveau d'une
classe de cm2 de 1987
la plupart du temps empreintes des
critères
qui correspondent au programme scolaire
passée or on sait que les programmes
évoluer qu'aujourd'hui on va demander à
des élèves des connaissances et des
compétences qui n'était pas demandée
elle serait ce que 20 ans ou 30 ans donc
la comparaison est très difficile quant
à la comparaison internationale
l'enquêteur juge la capacité de lecture
des élèves de cm1 sur 21 pays européen
loin derrière le luxembourg l'allemagne
ou la bulgarie
la france se classe seulement 16e peu
glorieux mais stable par rapport à 2001
l'étude pisa elle s'intéresse aux élèves
de 15 ans sur trophée de l' ocde les
français moyen se classe 19e en sciences
17e en mathématiques et à l'écrit
surtout la proportion d'élèves en
difficulté est passé de 15 à 22% en six
ans on pourrait dire que la performance
times le seul indice un peu inquiétant
c'est cette légère augmentation d'élèves
en difficulté si cette tendance perdure
dans les 20 prochaines années
on pourrait voir cette fois ci une
baisse de performance depuis vingt ans
la dépense par élève n'a cessé
d'augmenter
xavier darcos entend la réduire pour
améliorer les résultats il devra donc le
faire sans pénaliser les plus fragiles
l'environnement avec le succès des deux
roues écologique de quoi s'agit-il d'un
vélo à assistance électrique ilan
il est l'un des moyens de locomotion qui
émergent dix mille exemplaires vendus
l'an dernier gilles marine est arnaud
auguste l'ont testé pour nous voici le
reportage
ce n'est pas un col du tour de france
mais la côte est sévère d'ordinaire dans
cette rue de paris les cyclistes sont à
la peine mais certains depuis peu
affiche une aisance étonnante
le secret est là dans ces trous un
moteur électrique alimenté par des
batteries installées sur le
porte-bagages autonomie de ce modèle 50
km c'est la possibilité de retirer la
batterie pour les cervélo dans le
dans votre garage monter la batterie
chez vous et la recharge est plus
facilement
attention le pédalage en continu reste
obligatoire pour faire fonctionner
l'assistance électrique mais l'effort
est considérablement diminué
c'est agréable
cette agréable à conduire l'assistance
ne serait que fred beaucoup surtout pour
des gens qui comme moi ont mal au sens
pas d'immatriculation ni d'assurance
nécessaire pour ces vélos dont la
technologie ne semble pas contraignante
la partie d'étoilés demande aucun
entretien
les scooters à non parce que ça fait
c'est pas polluant à saint côté
écologique qui me plaît bien des
cyclistes soucieux d'environnement mais
aussi d'un certain confort j'aurais pu
opter pour le vélo et c'est c'est plus
un problème
on est en jeu c'est en costume j'ai pas
envie d'arriver
un peu moins
techniquement au point le vélo
électrique a tout pour s'imposer si ce
n'est son prix actuel 1500 euros en
moyenne pour les modèles pouvant
parcourir 50 km la santé avec la
deuxième phase de la campagne
d'information sur la contraception elle
est plus particulièrement destiné aux
moins de 20 ans et vise à réduire le
nombre d'interruptions volontaires de
grossesse
trois spots télévisés sont diffusés
jusqu'au 25 mai florence bouki à
virginie travers natacha à 19 ans c'est
une jeune fille épanouie et moderne
elle est salariée a un petit ami depuis
longtemps et depuis quelques mois fait
très attention à sa contraception car
natacha a dû avorter l'an dernier
j'avais oublié de prendre une pilule un
jour au lendemain je les reprises telles
que j'ai oublié puis j'en ai repris une
deuxième en plus de cinq pilules du
lendemain mais ça n'a pas fonctionné
puisque deux semaines après j'ai appris
que je suis tombé un médecin lui
prescrit alors une pilule abortive
mais cet avortement est un souvenir
douloureux pense que c'est très très
difficile je 206 milles ivg par an le
nombre d'avortements en france est
stable depuis 30 ans mais l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse est en
augmentation chez les mineurs et les
moins de 20 ans pourquoi peut-être parce
que comme natacha une femme sur cinq
oublie de prendre sa pilule au moins une
fois par mois le canyon bon jour pour le
planning familial
c'est bien la preuve que la pilule n'est
pas forcément le contraceptif le mieux
adapté à la femme
nous avons décidé de sortir si je peux
dire du tout pilule est de proposer tout
un échantillonnage de méthodes qui
existent maintenant le timbre là nous là
plan une piqûre un stérilet un bière
fran s'adresser d'abord aux jeunes c'est
ce que souhaite le ministère de la santé
qui diffuse des spots d'information sur
la contraception avec pastore gaulle et
que tu le fais un spot pour inciter les
jeunes à s'adresser aux bons
interlocuteurs
la disparition d'une voix familière
lucien jeunesse qui avait animé incarné
pendant trente ans le fameux jeu des
mille francs est mort il avait 89 ans
jean françois feer et virginie travers
son sens de la formule a fait sa
renommée celle du jeu des mille francs
lucien jeunesse
une voix qui accompagne pendant trente
ans le déjeuner des auditeurs de france
inter
de qui est ce roman c'est d'un bouche à
oreille
oh mais qui sont forains avec ce banal
jeu de questions réponses
l'animateur traverse la france chaque
jour la valise à la main
il fut une époque où on vous est
aujourd'hui paris demain auch
après-demain antibes et le troisième
jour strasbourg ce qui était très
fatigant mais également pour l'estomac
parce que entre le foie gras dans la
bouillabaisse et la choucroute il faut
quand même une solide voyez-vous quand
il en prend les commandes en 1965 le jeu
les mille francs fait encore partie du
programme du cirque pinder il le sort de
son chapiteau un an plus tard pour
l'amener dans les salles des fêtes et
dans les endroits les plus incongrus en
tournée dans notre région le célèbre jeu
des mille francs qui fait les beaux
jours de france inter a été enregistré
pour la première fois à bord d'un sous
marin
lucien jeunesse connaît le succès mais
pas celui qu'il espérait car l'homme de
radio qui sont avant tout artiste dans
les années 50 il est d'abord acteur puis
chanteur d'opérette
mais la mode est aux aguets
bon gré mal gré il accepte la
proposition de loi ps c'était un moyen
dans la lumière en plus il était en
scène il ya un vrai spectacle et pour
lui c'est fait le bonheur de billets
plus de trois coups mais il y avait le
public en 1995
lucien jeunesse décide brutalement
d'arrêter le jeu des mille francs depuis
il était apparu que rarement à la
télévision il disait ne pas vouloir
revenir sur le passé
en bref le décès également de l'écrivain
frédéric fajardie auteur d'une trentaine
de romans policiers historiques il avait
notamment les cris la nuit des chats
bottés il avait 60 ans une image de
sport bordeaux relance le championnat la
surprise générale en l'emportant hier
soit à marseille 2-1 mamadou niang avait
ouvert le score pour l'om égalisation de
wendel pour bordeaux sur ce coup franc
une lutte victorieuse de ducasse dans
les arrêts de jeu d'une frappe puissante
du coup bordeaux revient à deux points
de l'olympique lyonnais
à deux journées de la fin il y a encore
du suspense l'om pointe à la 4e place
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle deux des principaux titres
d'abord la birmanie durement frappé le
bilan du cyclone nargis s'est alourdi à
dix mille morts au moins il y aurait
plusieurs centaines de milliers de sans
abri la dictature militaire au pouvoir
acceptent de s'ouvrir à l'aide
internationale
et puis qui on veut à olivier besancenot
le porte parole de la lcr on l'a appris
en fin d'après midi a été espionné
pendant plusieurs mois par une officine
privée de renseignement sur ce plateau
il nous annonçait tout à l'heure qu'il
déposait plainte
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 fbi portés
disparus
23h10 mots croisés donc au tour d'yves
calvi à demain
l'info en continu cette audition france
2 point fr
non